how's it going bros my name
is oh God damn it here we go
again all right so I learned a lot from
the last comments or whatever you have
to maintain eye contact with this sexy
beast which is pretty hard not to do
please approach SCP
173 cuz he's a sexy beast but he's okay
and that blink bar that's you don't have
eye contem uh the door isn't responding
to any of our attempts to close it so um
please maintain a direct eye contact
with3 all right go how you doing how you
doing over there running out of whoa
what the hell where is he where is he
where is
he where is he ah no AA no AAR where is
he where is he where is he where is he I
see you I totally see
you hello oh God damn that intro is a
lot creepier what are you doing I can't
move yes yes yes yes yes totally agree
with your problem hey no and
[__] uh you out to Blink with space and
tab you read stuff all right here we go
special sexy beast is to be kept on
Locker container at all time when
personnel must enter no fewer than three
may enter at time the orbit cannot move
while within a direct line of sight line
of side must not be broken at any time
with and I have a gas mask all right
cool wa I feel badass now it's okay come
here [__] have have a badass gas all
right don't come here please I was
kidding let's take this [__] off what is
this battery
cool all right Venture furthering the
hell electrical sentence all right this
is where I need my hall pass
that's cool that's totally cool and I
save with F5 I think or maybe F5 I don't
know really let's try this hello oh
blood
cool all right here we
go another gas mask I don't really need
that more blood that cannot be good for
anyone God damn this is creepy am I
going feels like I'm going whatever
whatever all right same room twice
that's cool don't [__] with me I know a
lot of different
karate oh no not this room he so
mean so stupid looking too I'm sorry if
I offended you don't kill me oh God damn
it I knew
it all right what's going on here what
is he
doing
all right so he's in there hugging the
wall let's see what
this let blink here
hello where [__] you I blinked
no I blinked
blasted I did save though so it's
okay why did I blink I clicked space to
Blink I'm so stupid it was a
reflex all right here we go again I
wouldn't be oh it actually work over
here
okay let me get
this no no no all right I see
you what are you doing hi oh no no no no
no no
no [__] off [__]
up
oh
man
heus all right I acknowledge your
existance by looking at you whoa all
right cool oh no no no cool cool I'm
looking at you buddy girl look at
that stupid ass all right here we
go not a problem see that [__] oh what
the hell was that stop this nonsense
right now
all right we are good than
baseball bring
it God damn it he snook up on me that
little
[__] what what don't look at me like
that it's not easy ain't easy when you
lemon squeezy
peasy let's give it when have to try I
want to finish the card
TI whatever it
is oh he is [__]
you I look at
[Music]
you I looked I swear to God I looked at
him I pr you must look at him it's
totally not lame or anything I looked at
it I looked at that sweet ass and I like
mm but he that's why he killed me it
wasn't
because I burped I don't even care God
damn
it all right let's go in circles cuz I'm
triing all right here we go oh not you
close the door stop close close sorry
bro all
right
oh he goes through
doors oh my
God I [__] flew back
[__] oh my [__]
[Laughter]
god what I was
like oh my God that scared the [__] out
of me I didn't know you could walk
through doors a one of these days Bros
one of these days I tell
[Applause]
you okay so I kind of rushed my way
through the corridor whoa I see him
through the wall there you are you
little sexy beast I'm looking at you
this is going to be bad this is going to
be so bad I have to Blink
[__] all right you are too fat for me
I'm sorry
oh no no no oh oh that was close that
was oh no no [__] what am I doing so
stupid it's so difficult to sneak past
them okay but at least I got through the
first quarter it's ah I'm I'm seriously
playing without sound I'm such a [__]
right now I'm
sorry it's too
difficult all right so here we're safe
at least cool then he's here and he's
like suck you thought you got away from
me
I'm like yeah I
actually break my NE
[__] ah he's not in
here all right lucky me let's do a
[__] save there I don't know what
happened but I'm alive better wear these
gas masks to be
honest all right sounds on again I
guess okay gas mask off we just have to
find like
a not one of these
again no what are you doing here
[__] off behind
you I caught
you there we go oh no he's still here
where is
he he's still here he's still here he's
still here
cool all right let's go here God damn
this map is freaking me
out
oh no he's there
[__] I don't want to go where he is oh
stop
please [__] you sorry I'm I I I can't
play this right now anymore it's too
freaky and I will just I'm not focusing
on the horor I'm just like I just want
to finish it uh so I'm sorry if I didn't
make that much progress but I a little
progress that's good all right and I did
get pretty d I'm scared so you better be
happy and that's pretty much it
like I'll see you in next
episode AC charge
[__]
oh body lotion
power it doesn't
work [__]